i straight up cannot believe how much i
like this phone iphone and samsung
fanboys you guys have to check it out in
this review we're going to talk about
why this is such a gaming beast and some
of the amazing unique features that it
offers along with the downsides and who
should actually pick one of these up now
when paco reached out and they want to
sponsor us and send out one of these
phones i wanted to check it out but i
wasn't expecting a ton but as soon as i
took this thing out of the box i was
shocked first off they offer so much in
the box not only do we get a case a usb
c to a hyphen adapter but a 120
watt power brick with the extra long
angled usb type-c cable now before i
dive in i have to say that this phone
with over a 4700 milliamp hour battery
charges from zero to 100 in 17
minutes so each one of the batteries
that are split up inside take 60 watts
and you can literally see the percentage
rising as it is charging as we just wish
this animation stayed on screen longer
it is crazy not only that but it
actually didn't get that hot thanks to
its insane cooling system that is
designed for gaming and when you're
actually gaming and charging with that
90 degree cable that stays out of your
way you can actually go from 2 to 100 in
27 minutes
and this feature right here absolutely
blew my mind take a look at that these
pop-up triggers i was expecting them to
be a little bit janky but man they are
awesome now we'll talk about gaming in
just a bit but first let's talk about
the design and the build quality i was
expecting all of this just to be kind of
cheap because of that price point of 599
euros so just over 600 bucks for the
base model but it isn't we have all
aluminum we have gorilla glass victus on
the front in the back this super cool
looking gamery design with this little
lightning that actually is a flash which
is a cool touch now with the whole
camera module we also have rgb lighting
built in which you can use for
notifications texts and other things and
then on the sides we have our usb type c
port along with this very interesting
looking speaker grille now if we go to
the other side not only do we have the
earpiece speaker cut out we also have
that same speaker grille because this
thing has quad speakers but we also have
triple mics that are also positioned in
a way where that if you're gaming it
will still pick you up we have one on
the bottom right here next to that
volume rocker so those speakers the
quads are raised higher so they're also
not blocked like you get with other
phones and on top of that the wi-fi and
antennas are actually right here on the
side so when you're gaming you get the
best signal and of course if you're
using your phone with one hand it's also
not blocked so much thought went into
the design but as far as build quality
everything feels top notch including the
buttons the switches and what really got
me was the vibration motor typically on
cheap devices even more expensive
cheaper ones they put really sucky ones
in this felt really good and then i saw
on their website they were actually
advertising that it's the largest one in
an android phone and that's a little
detail that really makes it pleasant to
use now on the right hand side between
those triggers that lock up we have our
power button that is also a fingerprint
scanner now most of the time when you're
using it it is so quick that as soon as
you press it you're just logged in
because it scans your finger so fast so
far none of this is acting like a budget
phone now inside for the base model we
have eight gigs of ram and 128 gigs of
storage that can also jump up to 12 and
256. now those are good specs and as far
as the chip we have the best of the best
the snapdragon 8 gen 1 which not only
got a performance upgrades for our cpu
compared to the past but the biggest
jump was actually the graphics and that
is where it gets close to apple's a15
now as far as the display i was also
expecting to be let down because there
is no rating as far as the brightness
now this is a 1080p plus it's a 1920 by
2400 display it is an ola display but i
was expecting the brightness to be
limited when i raised up the brightness
though i was pleasantly surprised that
it was close to the brightness of
apple's flagship iphone now when you're
outdoors it actually works pretty well
and inside they don't limit the
brightness that you can manually kind of
reach it actually worked really well as
long as you have the auto toggle enabled
you can scroll the brightness and so
overall i was pretty happy with that now
before i go into hdr video in some more
details let's just jump into those
speakers once again we see that they're
offset here and there's two tweeters and
two woofers built in now this was
another area where i thought i was going
to be kind of disappointed not because
there's four of them but just because
it's a budget device and we just heard
that sony and it cost sixteen hundred
dollars and it did not sound good at all
well
i was quite impressed not only was it
louder than my iphone but it actually
had a nice natural sound where vocal
sounded nice and clear and not tinny at
all and along with that it had pretty
good bass much better than that sony
xperia 1 4. now my iphone does go deeper
with bass even though it just has two
speakers so apple's definitely heading
that but this thing really surprised me
and destroyed that sony now another area
i was really surprised by was the ui now
it's not a pixel ui you don't have the
gestures from the bottom but the command
center or whatever you call when you
pull back you have the brightness right
there automatically you have everything
you need easily accessible
so overall just going through everything
is so snappy with that 120 hertz screen
and i didn't feel annoyed by it like i
do with some other android software now
for those of you guys who watch a lot of
videos especially those that watch hdr
movies
it actually looks really good really
natural it does get bright about 800
nits but it doesn't have the super pop
in the highlights like you would get
from s22 ultra for 1200 bucks and now
let's talk about gaming what this phone
was actually designed to do and it did
an incredible job i have to say after
using these triggers and setting them up
easily you have a little pop-up menu you
move them where you want them and
getting used to doing the actions that i
do most in call of duty which is
shooting and reloading i don't know how
i'm going to go back to using an iphone
it just makes it so efficient to not
have to pick your fingers up and adjust
for those tasks that you're doing all
the time and not only that but this
screen actually has a 480 hertz refresh
sensitivity for touch um so it's way
more sensitive with way more zones as
well so when i was playing it was just
awesome to be able to have those
triggers um it just it's a whole nother
experience just like you'd have with a
gaming controller so they weren't janky
they weren't
bad feeling it wasn't gimmicky it is
legitimately really really nice to have
now with that i had all my settings
maxed out i had my brightness maxed out
and i had no dimming whatsoever
even when i plugged in the phone to
start charging as i was gaming the phone
did not dim now this thing has like i
said a crazy cooling system built in
multiple layers a huge surface area with
multiple materials the phone didn't get
hot and the screen didn't dim down it
was awesome not only call of duty which
is my favorite game but even gentian
impact with the settings maxed out we
did not have any issues and with the
iphone even though the performance is
higher because of that processor the a15
you do get quite a bit of dimming with
that phone so if you're somebody that
plays a lot of games
this experience i just don't know how
you can beat it even if you spend a lot
more money it is top notch now let's
talk about the camera system the main
camera is a 64 megapixel it's a nice
high-end sensor from sony and then you
also have an ultra wide and a macro
camera and then on the front we have an
upgraded uh front-facing camera as well
now this is where this phone starts
going towards a mid-range phone from a
flagship so many of the other things
like the design the performance the
display is either flagship level or very
high end the speakers the charging all
of that is great but the cameras
the main sensor will give you some
pretty good results and they are using
google camera for the actual
software to take your images so that
part of it is great but if you take a
lot of ultra photos or if you take a lot
of selfies this is where it's not
fantastic and of course it does not have
a portrait camera no telephoto like you
would get on a pro iphone or a high-end
samsung phone but if having the best
cameras is important to you this is
where this phone will not match up like
it does in all the other areas
now what are the other downsides well
first off there is no micro sd card slot
it's not a huge deal for me because so
many of the companies went away from it
obviously apple does not give that to
you in their phones and second what
matters more to me is the wireless
charging there is no wireless charging
built in so if you use that a lot that
is a downside now with the wire charging
being as fast as it is you kind of don't
need it but it still is a convenience
feature that you will get with higher
end flagships so overall with everything
this phone is offering i was really
surprised how well-rounded it is with
the display the speakers the ui being so
good and then of course the gaming
aspect of it i think for the money it is
an absolutely killer value and this is
gonna be my gaming phone now when i want
a game on my smartphone my iphone is
going to be chilling and i will be using
this just because of how dang good it is
especially with the no overheating and
with those triggers so there you guys go
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below check out the
links in the video description this has
been max and i will see you guys in the
next video